[Music]
and everybody welcome back to another
amazing episode of the careful boys very
careful
not today [ __ ] why oh no
that should be uh whoa ryan's off the
handle wow
they always do the same thing i was
doing the same
ryan gone wild holy [ __ ]
that was girl
that's like a dj drop ryan's off kilter
we're gonna we're gonna start with ryan
on this otr approach okay
yeah mr careful
so what we would like to discuss today
is your main source of confidence my
main source of guns this is a real one
we got it we gotta go we gotta break it
down [ __ ] big guns trap to get
clapped
[Laughter]
you never heard that before kick some
brass
i think you got that sticker on your
card
yeah rob this car there's a gun shove a
rifle down your throat you never heard
that before
that's a saying and people say that my
main source of confidence i think just
like getting older and realizing how
much [ __ ] doesn't matter like most
things that you don't like you care
about a lot in your early twenties
that's so true realize that like as much
effort as you put into those things
early on they end up not mattering or
looking back at people that are at that
age seeing them try so hard to like you
know be so confident in certain areas
and then just realizing that it's all
[ __ ] that's like i'm like i feel i
feel really good now what's one of those
instances where you're like man that was
all [ __ ] i think trying to impress
certain people like just trying to
impress certain people that you realize
later on in life don't really have that
much
weight over your over your life yeah
what's his or her name
wanting validation from someone yeah
yeah yeah i definitely had a lot of that
in high school and stuff like that like
authority figures and stuff that i was
like oh like if i do well in class or if
i you know contribute to a conversation
in a meaningful way like getting there
validation or whatever and they're
probably thinking about i can't wait to
go home to jack off or something i don't
know about that
i think all these high schoolers [ __ ]
get me too how to bother bro i would i
like to think that most of my high
school teachers were not pedophiles but
not most of them were okay statistically
yeah statistically yes
they were groomers
word you got to use now do you guys
remember like in high school like if you
had a [ __ ] up haircut you just refused
to go to school the next day because you
just thought that you would be so
ridiculed by everything everyone's
looking at you oh my god oh [ __ ] i can't
everyone sees you they're gonna [ __ ]
roast me so hard i remember doing my
hair for like two hours yeah like i
would do it it didn't turn out right
[ __ ] and then the gel starts drying oh
go take another shower
come back up do it again i'm like oh
it's [ __ ] drying on me again [ __ ] i
can't go [ __ ] gang bang looking like
this
did you walk to school or like what did
you not like i don't even know it's
right there you had to look good when
he's asking someone where they're from
it is honestly the most vain time of
your life because you think everyone's
looking at you nobody gives a [ __ ] well
it's also it's not your life people are
scrutinizing you though like outwardly
you know i remember like my parents have
a dry cleaner so they have [ __ ] like
professional pressing machines and my
mom [ __ ] took my jeans and she
pressed them
that's tight like a cholo
she creased your crease on the front
like a suit pants [ __ ] and i remember
being like mom i'm gonna think i have
more
you can't crease some [ __ ] jeans a
cholo out there is looking at you like
you ungrateful [ __ ] yeah cause they're
like dude i wanted all my dickies and
jeans all creased dude it was it was
embarrassing and starched but
for no reason but yes that is that is a
very very uh valid and great point
but i don't i don't think that it's a
thing that you can like learn you just
like have to like experience enough of
it and eventually you're just like i
don't care you know yeah yeah and some
people don't ever get over it like
they're still self-conscious and
you know blessings
all right anybody else main source of
coffee dolls
i would say confidence will
morph or how you get that confidence
will morph over the years because i
think as you're developing your identity
is always like picking
general like things about you and
thinking that's who you are so for
example i'm like i'm an asian male right
so that becomes who i am i'm a high
schooler or like i'm a college student
and then and then it might expand into a
skill like i'm a skater and i'm good at
skating or like i'm a comedian i'm funny
and i'm good at being funny right and
then like i think at least for guys
maybe it's like an external thing that
you collect and you get good at all
these things and people like oh yeah i
like hanging out with this oh i like
picking this guy on my team because he's
good at playing this and then that
becomes your identity and then when you
start sucking at it or someone's better
than that
better than you at that skill then it
starts lowering your confidence and then
you can mature even more and realize
none of that [ __ ] [ __ ] matters
yeah yeah sure it's just do you like
yourself as a human being yeah what's
something that you tied to that like
what was your what was your thing that
you feel like you you tie or like the
most consistent thing that you tied your
self-worth to i think um it was yeah
skill based it was mainly
which skill though specifically uh
comedy and being funny because i made it
a career as well so then there was so
much tied to that right so like me being
successful on youtube
me being um called funny or like
seeing people laugh from what i do and
so it's been a thing of mine that i can
always go back to and know that i could
make somebody like laugh
and but then eventually like not
everyone has the same taste right
because you know when you get really
really deep into an art form or whatever
like
you you get so into it that it's like
this weird snobby phase
oh bro yes right and then you're and
then you think everyone else is stupid
for having different tastes which is
like ridiculous it's a young thing to do
yeah but everyone has different like
likes and dislikes right but then you
wanna you want everyone to like you and
if they don't like you you feel like
they're dumb and everyone else is dumb
and they just don't get it because
they're not as good as you and i think
that's kind of but that's the insecure
part that's the insecure part you don't
really think that they're not as good as
you you're just trying to project that
outwardly because you're you're like
you're soft and you need the porcupines
to protect your little soft body yeah
it's like all the [ __ ] film students
that think they're they're spielberg
right all the and then they're like
critiquing all these masters as if
they're on the same playing field and
they're all saying the same [ __ ] like in
american beauty in the beginning the bag
in the wind is like yeah bro it's the
most beautiful everyone [ __ ]
knows that part dude they all know the
meaning behind that part dude you're not
[ __ ] seeing something nobody else is
seeing you stupid dumb [ __ ] like
shit's funny though but it is it is a a
formative time though to do that to
porcupine yeah right we all do that
don't we all do that still
uh no we're over it oh we're over it now
we're better and more we're out of it
super mature and comfortable we're in
the ivory tower looking down and
pointing yeah i think uh it helps though
to get so beaten down
because confidence also has a mix of ego
and thinking that you can actually do
something a little bit better than
everybody else right
and then that's why
uh you're just like
oh you know um i i believe in myself but
then also when you identify with that
thing so [ __ ] hard that it that it
kind of like
you can't tell the difference between
you as an a character that's a player in
this game of art
and you just as a human being when you
mesh those two things together and that
becomes your identity and then you start
sucking at it or maybe you're not
winning all the time or maybe you're
number three and then you're just
beating yourself up like you're not good
enough and you're not you're not worthy
of a of a of just existing anymore i
don't know if that's something that
people i think i actually relate super
hard to that because um i think my
confidence came from having like a
really awkward and uh unrelatable
childhood
so like my parents got divorced when i
was six right and then so from a mom to
a four the mortgage
uh i slept in the same bed as my mom all
the time like 13.
so that's [ __ ] weird all the homies
come over like what the [ __ ]
and then so we have roommates random
strangers in our house that's how we ran
off the other three rooms remember this
for later yeah we're gonna get that yeah
the content is very nice
but i just wanna never know i can't wait
13
now though but we'll compliment them
right now
hey at least your mom had big tips
that's right it's called
braggable and they're all friends here
i told the story before too where like i
was at a boy scout uh meeting right
where there's like it's like a big like
ceremony where people are getting like
promoted or whatever and then all the
adults are sitting on the chairs in
front of us all the kids are sitting
across they get behind and my mom just
[ __ ] tilts one of her ass cheeks up
and just goes
and i'm like [ __ ]
court of honor yeah so that that's like
my whole childhood so i think my whole
childhood which is so [ __ ] up nothing
made sense that was bart's whole
childhood like his mom's part no it was
just it just summed up in a weird way
that i think um
understanding that you could bounce back
like me spending spring breaks at that
hacienda heights
temple over there like living in a
monastery for like during third grade
and fourth it's just [ __ ] weird so
like i think just understanding that my
life isn't normal but then also
it doesn't really you could always come
back from it doesn't mean anything it
doesn't really mean anything no matter
how [ __ ] up your life is it's in your
own mind because everyone else is living
their own
life and that helped me understand like
oh [ __ ] then you could literally do
whatever you want and it doesn't even
matter what the circumstances are very
true to piggyback off of that
i think for me my confidence comes from
this weird eerie thing that i have which
i feel like i've known my whole life
huge penis huge huge huge [ __ ]
four-year-old it was just [ __ ]
throbbing the fatty
my right was trying to help me watch it
couldn't get her hand all the way around
it
all right
my mom has little tips
why would you bring that up
she's actually the chairman of the itty
bitty community
not the story that we're on not right
now um
no
um mama has breast cancer actually
[ __ ]
okay so she has one big teeth making it
too real
you're making it too real
uh that's what i did about my uncle by
the way who had aids he died and i was
like maybe the two my uncle had aids
every time somebody did the aids joke in
the comedy room i was like my uncle died
of aids uh-huh did anyone go in on it
afterwards no they would all like they'd
all get weird and i was like
i'm sorry i'm just [ __ ] around i'm
sorry i think i'm a gift i know but no
um honestly this is a little bit bad
it's this weird spirit i'm [ __ ] dude
i don't give a [ __ ] um no i was this
weird thing that i have where i really
do feel like i'm not better than anybody
um and it's and it but it goes uh
reversed too
i don't think anyone's better than me
yeah so it's like i can look around and
everyone goes that person's the special
person that person special and stuff and
i don't see them that way i just see
them as the same as me and this like
weird like zen [ __ ]
every time i read about buddhism i'm
like oh that's pretty much exactly how i
feel like i don't see anyone go oh yeah
you
are a special
yeah get the glow or something on a
pedestal [ __ ] no i don't know yeah for
me it's like no you're we're all the
same i'm not better than anybody ever
i don't think anyone else is better than
anybody ever and that's why i think
anyone can win i really do think that so
you're saying
your penis my opinion same level same
exact length
and girth girth thank you
congratulations
it's a mushroom i don't even know it's
about i don't even know it's great news
ratio-wise
it's by percentage by weight by exactly
no but um and that that honestly like i
i just have this like weird sense of
like you were a kid you had this thing i
was a kid yeah it's just weird it's a
weird thing where it's like i really do
think that anyone can do anything that
they that they want to if they if they
choose to do something like that when
you were a kid because yeah i didn't
start thinking this way until like a
couple years ago where i started to
realize that like oh yeah nobody is
nobody's necessarily special in a lot of
ways like i used to hold so many
different people that are more
successful or whatever the case may be
on a pedestal just because like oh
they're there's they have special
talents or this but i remember in first
grade
you know for the first like one of the
main halloweens this kid he came to
school with the [ __ ] electric guitar
around his [ __ ] shoulder i'm like
this guy [ __ ] wanting life yeah i'm
like this guy he has it all i don't even
know where to buy electric guitar he's
got a [ __ ] rock star he's six years
old there's nowhere to plug in yeah i'm
like there's no ant [ __ ] man
i'm better than that guy
everyone else equal but that guy i'm
better than come on no but but there is
no yeah i think for me i mean obviously
you fall you're a human you fall into
the trap so like yeah sometimes you
catch yourself maybe thinking somebody
is a special thing but there's always
like this mean that i go back to like
this like base level that i go back to
where i'm like oh no no no i i remember
now like i like because the more the
closer i've been to successful people
the more i realize nobody knows what the
[ __ ] they're doing yeah and and you just
see that universally playing out with
people like the more i know people it's
it's fast but you don't feel like
there's ever a point where you were
where you didn't have that because i
didn't i didn't realize that until later
i was like oh these people are just
super self-motivated later in the on in
life i was like oh these people are on
adderall
yeah yeah you know stuff like that where
you're just like oh i thought these
people were just like better than me but
he's like oh no they're on drugs
everyone's not just [ __ ] like
something else i think i just had this
like i said it's like this weird thing i
i feel very connected to my spiritual
self and i've i've always just felt this
like weird piece about it where it's
like
and like honestly too the the ladder
that we all climb in life there's so
much vanity in it like it's so much for
for like what people think of me and all
the [ __ ] that we all do like like
but so to me it's all funny like i could
see all the funny in it i love that part
that's that's my favorite part about
being a human being is just getting to
look at human beings
and like our existence is silly
um but the
the vanity stuff that we all fall
traps to we all do yeah um yeah i never
care like like i was telling you guys
like a bunch of my whale buddies in
crypto they're buying like crazy watches
like hundred thousand dollars 150 000
watches and [ __ ] and i bought this casio
g-shock just as a [ __ ] you because like
well you guys are silly this is just as
shiny as your stupid watch
and this has more utility than your
stupid watch i'm gonna get you a nice
watch yeah 230 dollar one nice watch
and you're gonna be angry about it i'll
be kidding you're gonna be smearing
can't i know i like this one by quartz
but that's what i mean i don't it's i
don't actually
care about that stuff it's just i just
find it funny if anything so i think
when you're um
when you when you're not like
living kind of cookie cutter right or
like when you're not in this mold of
being embarrassed like everybody else
about the same things like for example
like let's say most people will look and
dress decent before they go somewhere
like the mall where most of us probably
maybe outside of youtube guys would go
in there looking like [ __ ]
right like exactly right but but then
most people i would say would
would have that in their head to go oh
i'm you know time and place i should
dress a certain way for this occasion
where like i'd be completely blind to
that so i have my own set of values and
things though that i do get embarrassed
about that other people won't and that's
what i realized because a lot like for
you know for most of my life people be
like oh man dude i wish i could not give
a [ __ ] like you like i hear it all the
time and i'm like what are you talking
about i give a [ __ ] about so many things
just not the things that you care about
society does yeah yeah yeah so then
like the things that most people will
value
like
like things that make you a decent human
being like keeping things clean like
your car and your clothes and things
like
of a certain standard right because
you don't want to be judged or whatever
it is it's normal but for me if i'm on a
like task or something like my mind is
so zero focused in on that i might not
[ __ ] you know
brush or shower or whatever like you
know what i mean like it's just that's
all i obsess about and i think that's
also why i was able to achieve certain
things without worrying about the
outcomes because i'm so obsessed about
it that it's not even something i
consider that i can be looked upon or
judged
like oh someone's gonna talk about you
if you do this or like if you pursue
this or if you try to do youtube what
about people that are like gonna
ridicule you i'm like they're not
sucking my dick
like i'm they're not bit i'm not
benefiting from you know them like yeah
like i'm doing this to get my dick
sucked you know what i mean like
but that's that's kind of some something
that i've realized recently is that oh
when i want something
then i just want it so bad that anything
else that might worry me around it
doesn't exist so it's kind of like this
stupid impulsive obsession towards
something but this is why we're all
friends i think honestly like for a long
time because like i think we have that
same thing where it's like
you slept in your mom's bedroom i slept
in my mom and she has big titties
dude
she's cancer man sorry i'm sorry that's
sorry
i'm sorry
no but there's there is something to
like you know there's like this weird
like um
understanding i think we all have of
like it's like no matter what we all do
we can make fun of that thing that we do
or that we're known for instantly like
quickly because it's all silly serious
it's not that serious exactly it's just
it's it's really just
silly mode like why is everyone why does
everyone take so many things so
seriously that's true like like he's
really into golf right now right yeah
rag on him destroy him with golf but i'm
also going to get into golf too
that's why you rag on me for dance which
is like i'm really into as well for a
long time my whole career has been
defined by it yeah but it's still silly
it is it's very silly but golf is just
too easy i think you know what's silly
uh
and i know some of us will relate to
this um maybe because we're in like
entertainment and stuff like that right
um when we think about the basic prompt
of like what gives you confidence
to be vulnerable i have to admit like
[ __ ] people online sometimes give me
confidence which is is both a
double-edged sword right yeah the
validation but they all absolutely you
put out it's like a dangerous game
anthony i know i know i know but you
know like i [ __ ] do things like dance
videos like where you're really
expressing a very very sensitive and
vulnerable internal element of your
expressive side right you put it out
there
and then the irony is like when you do
stuff like for the views when you do
stuff for a certain things oftentimes
like the shallowness that you put out is
the shallowness that you receive good or
bad right and then there's also times
where it's like you put out something
that means [ __ ] a shitload to you
you're not looking for anything else and
that's the thing that
resonates most with people right so
there's that time there's that
validation there's that moment
especially in the type of career that
i've been a part of i guess
however unique or not unique that is
where it's like you get confidence from
people
for doing what you do but then the
double-edged sword is that there are
also times where especially as a creator
as an artist you're [ __ ] insecure
you're very hyper-sensitive just as
sensitive as you are to receiving
validation you're overly critical in
receiving criticism
right if somebody's just not into it
you're it's not easy to brush off
because if you put weight in the value
of the things that people said were good
then you also are capable of putting
weight in the things that are like not a
mistake and that's such a conflict and
that's a tough thing to do because
how do you how do you do that you know
how do you how do you only take the good
and not take the bad consistently
without finding yourself in you take the
good from your inner circle yeah
that's the biggest thing and the bad so
so i remember in like 2000 maybe like 14
15 or something like that i remember
being in just just a funk just like uh
not far enough where i would myself call
it like depression but just a funk
nothing like made sense something hit
music didn't hit the right way food
didn't taste as great whatever the [ __ ]
you want to call it that's depression
man i know what you're talking about
but but i remember again just off the
prompt of confidence i remember the only
thing that got me out of that sunken
spot
was i had to rationalize because i think
i'm also a rational person i'll be like
all right
everything about my life is wack i'm
[ __ ] shitty i'm piece of crap dance
or whatever the [ __ ] however all of my
homies are sick as [ __ ]
and if they're you know if they're
willing to spend time with me i have to
at the minimum be decent you got a
redeeming quality exactly so that was
the only thing that really made i found
confidence in myself by validating
others around me and i feel like that
was one of the most powerful tools i was
able to teach myself through that time
period because now no matter how low
things get
i know that if i got people like you
[ __ ] around me i can't be that bad or
at least y'all will keep me in check and
i think that's super important for
everybody's journey yeah amen i love
that for sure that's true i think that's
how we were able to survive so long in
like on youtube where a lot of our peers
they um they leave and get sick of
social media and like
because they get the validation from the
comments i mean i appreciate the
comments i appreciate our fan base and
all that but also we never really
cared about the subscriber count the
view count the you know people don't
believe you but i know i know you're
telling the truth but they don't believe
you yeah whether we're getting 8 000
views or a million views like we've been
on youtube for this is next year is
going to be 16 years
and like i've loved every step of the
way because it was just like you know
like the process of connecting with
people and being able to create and just
being able to live off of creating that
alone is just [ __ ] amazing and then
like over the years you might get kind
of like lost in the sauce and you're
just this is everyday life you get too
used to it but then you go back and this
like the inner circle like creating
together the
the the camaraderie and in the support
the the humans around me
that i think
is where i get my real validation versus
um
you know a lot of people who are just
hitting the like button
so yeah yeah but they should hit the
like button please
with the algorithm smash that like
button help with the algorithm ring that
bell make sure you hit that notification
bell in the corner helps a lot too
uh
as someone who but real real quickly
before bart cuts me off
he's like steve's about to say something
let's turn it off
no no as someone wanted this 15 minutes
ago
[Laughter]
i don't have a trained eye right so when
i watch something like like i don't
necessarily know what i'm looking at
looks like when you're dancing like on a
video like i don't know what's going on
but if you guys aren't in sync i'm like
this video sucks
[Laughter]
that's the last thing you needed to add
[Music]
[Music]
you